[Musique]
finir premier du groupe de la mort et
perdre contre la suisse les internautes
français ont du mal à digérer la défaite
alors certains imaginent se défouler
dans les vestiaires quand d'autres
manient l'ironie en félicitant la
défense française pour le bon respect de
la distanciation social avec les
attaquants suisses malgré ses excuses
publié sur instagram mbacké est la cible
de beaucoup de montage certains
voudraient juste lui dire domaine
quand d'autres l'imaginent déjà à pôle
emploi si vous cherchez le chat noir
sachez que c'est le premier match de
cette euro que ma femme regarde regarde
heures raconte par exemple un internaute
mesdames dit un autre vous allez
découvrir ce matin vos maris dans un
état émotionnel à ces extrêmes
certains pensent que c'est dommage qu'on
ait joué à bucarest et pas sur le papier
parce que sur le papier on avait la
meilleure équipe du monde
c'est dur à encaisser c'est compliqué ça
devait être de la folie en suisse hier
soir dire d'internautes ils ont dû se
coucher vers minuit minuit et quart
00h15 selon le tweet du magazine so foot
les bleus se sont fait éliminer par
leurs banquiers hier monsieur collard je
vous en prie montrer monsieur collard et
monsieur collard c'est entrer la fashion
plus la révolution je m'appelle base et
j'ai 70 ans
stupid j'ai 68 ans on est les meilleurs
et les plus vieux du monde jargon de
rapports adoptés bmw aux vitres teintées
incarnez un duo à rim
on écrit sur notre vie pour devenir un
homme tu as besoin d'une leçon rentrer
ta chemise rebond ton pantalon si tu
piges par écoute se sont pas beaucoup
voilà c'est pas possible machine mais en
direct en direct je serai très polis
mois dites bonjour à monsieur joffrin on
dirait on est enterré geoffrey vous
allez bien mais on est à l'antenne la
lèbe alors monsieur joffrin vous allez
bien voilà souhaitent non sans ironie je
marche pas non plus la courtoisie
républicaine pourquoi vous parlez comme
la preuve était de gauche ou après il va
vous traiter de facho il a fait déjà ce
que vous avez commencé
et toi la ferme là on et d'hévéa ils ont
dix ans d'ouvrir des voyous atypique
vous avez fait une psychanalyse je crois
ce qui vous donne cette liberté de ton
et de parole et avec jacques lacan plus
éthérée rue donc on voit les epci cas
d'élise et on vous êtes désinhibés par
la psychanalyse du désinhibe pas dur je
ne dis pas tout ce qui passe par la tête
parce que sinon ça donne ça donne un
rapport au réel qui est analysé voilà
ses toiles à la pression hospitalière ne
cesse de baisser partout en france dans
ce service de l'hôpital de l'île seuls
deux patients sont soignés contre le
coronavirus pour la plus grande joie du
personnel qui peut enfin se reposer
le nombre de primo vacciner chute de
façon absolument préoccupante
donc moi c'est simple les non vaccinés
ce sont des dangers publics pour les
autres
donc moi j'ai une démarche qui est très
clair c'est je fais tout pour en faire
des parias de la société dire que vous
ne voulez pas vous faire vacciner vous
mettez la vie des autres en danger et
vous mettez la vôtre aussi mais sans
peux pas vous le reprocher eh ben vous
ne bénéficiez pas des mêmes droits que
les autres citoyens
le variant poussent les autorités à
maintenir la cadence de la vaccination
s'ils ne représentent que 10% des cas
actuellement en france selon les
scientifiques le variant delta pourrait
représenter 90% des cas en europe dit
si la fin août donc à un moment où la
connerie ça suffit l'obligation
convaincre on voit bien que ça sert à
rien tous les gens qui défilent sur
notre antenne qui ne veulent pas se
faire vacciner
ils sont de plus en plus irréductibles
au fil des jours avec des arguments de
plus en plus nul et j'espère que ce
qu'on aura aujourd'hui ils ont un peu
plus de biscuits que on sait pas dans
quinze ans que ça va donner et c'est moi
les attend l'a appelé et je viens combes
est un abruti monsieur nous sommes tous
d'accord pour le dire aujourd'hui
alors moi c'est moi qui ai dit c'est mon
opinion je dois d'abord une vidéo sur
nous mêmes
bon téléphoner et on vous vaccinera deux
forces nous ferait non aidés par deux
policiers au centre de vaccination
parfaitement le tj j'espère que tu es
passé dixième je suis très sérieux faut
aller les chercher avec les dents
diop et avec les menottes s'il faut ça
va ça mais faut que tu te calmes un tout
petit peu vous êtes vous déjà demandé si
les animaux criaient aussi regarder ce
chien et ce cheval franchement on a
l'impression qu'ils se fendent la poire
on le pense parce que cette mimique
ressemble à la nôtre quand on rit en
réalité selon la majorité des chercheurs
les animaux ne rit pas secret' n'est pas
une chaîne comme les autres ce berger
australien est en passe de devenir une
superstar de tik tok toujours prêtes
pour réaliser ses meilleures poses de
yoga en duo avec sa maîtresse mairie
avant de lui donner un petit coup de
main pour les tâches ménagères
une relation de confiance totale et un
apprentissage qui va même jusqu aux
nouvelles technologies secret' semble en
effet lancer elle-même l'enregistrement
de sa vidéo avant de faire sa petite
chorégraphie pour ses fans je te
caresser d'achat mais bien sûr c'est
figé up à l'aise tout ça est très très
douce et les carters de bouche ça fait
longtemps qu'on n'a pas écarté la bouche
comme ça j'ai donné mes plats pour leur
santé permette l école c'est un aspect
de toi conte des cours je pense que ça
nous est tous inspiré trois précités
stasio jeune et pétillante une belle
promesse dont je tombais sur people
abusé de tomber sur pire quand même si
tu devais choisir un plat qui te
ressemble ce serait quoi et rognons roma
der sar à sophie elle mon bébé mieux
j'espère que de mieux en mieux on est
bien et moi j'ai une grosse envie
d'aller aux toilettes là les mouvements
mais tout très ému avec les techniciens
avec les techniciens aussi en régie il
est sur sa totalité au quai réaliste
dernier dernier au bout de combien de
j'ai 32 ans 32 ans alors on voulait
juste se te dire avec tous les amis que
tu vas nous manquer leur payant tu vas
nous manquer
[Musique]